obi-wan kenobi is one of the most iconic
characters in the star wars universe but
who knew he owes his origins to a
certain late night talk show host keep
watching to discover the untold truth of
obi-wan kenobi
fans are often divided by george lucas's
late career contributions to the star
wars franchise in some ways it can feel
like he's both the best and worst thing
to ever happen to the saga and for a
long time at least whatever lucas said
about his universe would quickly become
law even if he was joking at the star
wars celebration 5 in 2010 lucas was
being interviewed by jon stewart who
observed that while we know about the
homeworlds of most of the saga's main
characters obi-wan kenobi's is a mystery
so he posed the question just where does
obi-wan hail from at this point lucas
paused to think spurring stewart to
insist that he not just make up his
answer lucas sarcastically shot back
that he'd never make something like this
up then proclaimed that obi-wan's
homeworld is the planet of stujon an
obvious amalgamation of jon stewart's
name while this was obviously an offhand
joke for lucas the nature of lucas's
influence on star wars means it's now
enshrined in canon if you visit
obi-wan's page on the official star wars
site you'll even find that stu john is
listed as his homeworld on his databank
profile
in the star wars universe there's
something to be said about the bond
between a padawan and a master as jedi
are instructed to forsake their
emotional ties and relationships a
padawan's closest familial bond becomes
the one who instructs them in the ways
of the force as a result there's a kind
of lineage that can be spoken of in the
ranks of the jedi one that transcends
genetic relationships why do i get the
feeling you're going to be the death of
me
don't say that master
you're the closest thing i have to a
father
obi-wan kenobi is perhaps the most
pivotal and influential jedi master in
star wars
not only did he train the greatest sith
lord in the galaxy his own skills and
training can be traced back to the
ancient era of the high republic during
this time the thriving republic was
expanding to the outer territories
within the galaxy and the jedi were at
their very peak how does this work well
in the empire strikes back it's implied
that yoda trained obi-wan but the
prequel trilogy makes it quite clear
that the bulk of his training came from
qui-gon jinn it's later revealed however
that jin was trained by count dooku who
was in turn trained by yoda so no matter
how you spin it obi-wan's skills are
derived from yodas and yoda learned his
powers as a padawan nearly a millennium
prior during the high republic era it's
one heck of a long line and one that
stretches not just into the past but far
into the future too
obi-wan's journey from the galactic
republic to the galactic empire is
driven by his incessant need to do the
right thing and live by the jedi code in
the prequel films he often appears to
harp on anakin for acting outside the
tenets of the jedi and he rarely wavers
in his loyalties to the jedi council
there is however one notable exception
to this
sadly only one film in the saga portrays
the relationship between obi-wan and his
master qui-gon jinn but it's a
fascinating one nonetheless
throughout the phantom menace obi-wan
objects to his master's decision to
bring anakin skywalker into the jedi
fold but he supports qui-gon regardless
qui-gon meanwhile constantly challenges
the council and is clearly unwilling to
fall in line behind their agenda
especially when they deny his request to
have anakin trained sticking to his
convictions qui-gon commits to teaching
anakin in his dying breath qui-gon asks
obi-wan to train anakin insisting he is
the chosen one risking his standing
among the jedi council obi-wan remains
loyal to his dying master's request and
assumes mentorship over the young
padawan despite his own feelings and the
council's original decision obi-wan's
loyalty to qui-gon jinn clearly runs far
deeper than his own commitment to the
jedi at one point he even tells yoda
that he'll go against the council's
wishes if he doesn't have their support
just like qui-gon it's a stirring
testament to the incredibly close
relationship between obi-wan and his
former master jedi knights are known for
their prowess in the use of the force
and obi-wan kenobi became a legend among
them by defeating darth maul in the
phantom menace of course darth maul
would return to skulk in the shadows for
years to come but as far as the prequels
go their battle is as important as it is
dramatic at the time of their duel a
sith lord had not been seen in nearly a
thousand years defeating and seemingly
killing one solidified obi-wan's
position among the top ranks of the jedi
and he was granted the rank of jedi
knight for accomplishing this feat the
sith are capable and dangerous foes to a
jedi for a reason as they're less
constrained by the moral platitudes of
the jedi order simply put defeating a
sith lord is no mean feat even for a
jedi master obi-wan's victory over darth
maul given his relative youth and
inexperience is one of his greatest and
most under-appreciated accomplishments
while the duel between obi-wan and darth
maul marks the climax of the phantom
menace the two would be destined for
many more rounds via the franchise's
animated shows
on at least three occasions in the clone
wars and rebels obi-wan and darth maul
have been reunited in combat it's soon
revealed that darth maul's connection
with the force as well as his intense
hatred for obi-wan kept him alive after
being severed in two
eventually he obtained robotic legs that
enabled him to once again operate like
normal however he grew resentful towards
the jedi for taking away his future at
palpatine's side maul's brother savage
oppress soon located him and the two set
off on their own path toward building a
criminal empire
ultimately just prior to the events of a
new hope darth maul discovers that
obi-wan is hiding on tatooine and
deduces that he must be serving a
purpose there or protecting somebody he
hunts down his old enemy but after a
brief clash obi-wan delivers him a fatal
wound in maul's dying breath he asks
obi-wan if the one he protects is the
chosen one obi-wan confirms this and
maul dies believing that this chosen one
will avenge them both clearly maul
always knew the sith were his true
enemies having stolen him as a child and
indoctrinated him in the ways of the
dark side and while luke skywalker
didn't avenge maul in quite the way he
might have thought obi-wan's mission to
protect and train the young jedi
nevertheless delivered justice for the
embittered ex-sith lord
the jedi ahsoka is known for many things
one being that she was the only jedi
apprentice of anakin skywalker prior to
his turn to the dark side of the force
her quest to becoming a jedi begins in
the clone wars animated series as anakin
trains the young padawan into becoming a
fully-fledged jedi knight most of the
time obi-wan anakin and ahsoka operate
together on missions and obi-wan is
typically on hand to aid anakin in his
efforts to train his apprentice
likewise ahsoka recognizes obi-wan's
status in the jedi order often going
directly to him to seek guidance and the
two forge a unique bond tragically
following order 66 ahsoka and obi-wan
never made contact again as they're both
forced into hiding from the empire it's
quite likely that he never even knew
that she survived the purging of the
jedi
while obi-wan may be a legendary jedi
knight he isn't infallible most of his
shortcomings are due to the rigid
traditions of the jedi order that
obi-wan adheres to with precision
indeed perhaps his most destructive flaw
is his aversion to matters of the heart
the jedi have always denied their
emotions and romantic attachments to
others but this makes them more
susceptible to volatility and
instability the result
this
[Music]
obi-wan is particularly adherent to this
rule and it even prevents him from
discussing his padawan's obvious
attraction to padme had this been an
open topic for discussion perhaps
obi-wan could have circumvented
palpatine's efforts and reasoned with
anakin before tragedy struck likewise
his fear of impacting the fate of the
galaxy by bringing up family trauma
prevents him from telling luke the
identity of his real father in return of
the jedi obi-wan counsels luke to kill
his father a task luke doesn't think he
can perform obi-wan then laments a
failure that hadn't even occurred
of course luke's love for his father
later brings about the downfall of the
empire proving that the jedi and obi-wan
himself were very much in the wrong
in a 2015 run of star wars comics
published by marvel luke discovers
obi-wan's old journals issue number
seven written by jason aaron details an
adventure in which he rescued luke from
jabba's enforcers as a young boy at the
time luke had become angered by jabba's
henchmen collecting water tax from the
moisture farms
after attempting to steal the water back
luke was caught and came very close to
being sold into slavery
luckily for the intrepid little
do-gooder old ben kenobi had been
watching his back from the shadows
obi-wan leapt into action using the
force to dispatch luke's captors the
next morning luke awakened to aunt peru
asking him what had happened he stated
that he simply could not remember
this would seem to imply that ben kenobi
used the force to wipe luke's memory of
the event true to his word and purpose
this wasn't the only time that obi-wan
has demonstrated his watchful eye and
protective actions over luke
the most famous of these of course
occurs in live action when he scares
away the tuscan raiders in a new hope
and there can be little doubt that he'll
get the chance again when obi-wan kenobi
airs on disney plus in 2022
building an evolving story that grows
both backwards and forward can be
extremely difficult work for george
lucas modernizing old plot points
eventually became a tug of war with
simply telling solid stories leading to
some substantial plot holes in his
franchise one such trouble spot comes
from obi-wan apparently having forgotten
r2d2 and c-3po from his days as a young
jedi knight despite all the adventures
they shared together when alec guinness
sees the droids in a new hope he barely
even acknowledges them well then the joy
does belong to you i don't seem to
remember ever owning a drawing one fan
theory argues that obi-wan may have
voluntarily erased any memory that
connected him with the dissidents of the
empire in order to protect himself and
luke it's a nice idea but nothing exists
in canon to support it and for now fans
will have to assume that in a new hope
old ben kenobi is simply showing his age
at first pass it might seem odd that han
and leia named their son after the name
obi-wan took in exile after all han
barely knew ben kenobi sure the old man
had tagged along with luke aboard the
millennium falcon but he died at the
hands of darth vader mere hours later
after the crew was pulled aboard the
death star obi-wan engages in few
notable interactions with solo and even
leia knew him primarily from his
reputation that said both of them were
aboard the death star and if not for
obi-wan's diversion and sacrifice the
whole group might have been killed
most likely as the years went by luke
shared obi-wan's stories with his sister
and brother-in-law perhaps suggesting
that ben kenobi had helped bring the two
of them together suddenly the name ben
makes a little more sense for the child
of han and leia it's just a shame what
happened next
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]